let's talk about some of the stuff
that's happened more recently because
one of the things that we we know now is
that there was some criticism of you and
an attempt to present you in a
particular light and I wanted to speak
to you about that and see what you had
to say about it because there was this
video released it's an 18 minute video I
found it quite boring and difficult to
watch but basically if if I can
represent what is being said about it
and then you can say what you think
about it
and correct me if any of my thing is not
accurate to what people are saying right
what I think people are saying is you
were part you were walking together with
a right-wing group of is a patriot
prayer right who who were planning to
attack a bar in which these anti-fur
people hang out and you were
participating or at least observing a
conversation in which they were planning
this violent attack and people have used
that to essentially say and Andino is
not an objective journalist what he is
is someone who hates auntie fur so he
records all their violent crimes but
when it comes to right-wing violence
which also does exist he doesn't record
that he doesn't present that and
therefore he presents a skewed picture
and they've then gone on to say that
that's why you left Collette so tell us
about that yes so I left her like a week
before the latest controversy broke out
it was a mutual decision I'm moving on
to other projects I'm going to be
working on a book just don't have time
to continue to be working with Colette
and it's been a great experience and
very thankful for the time that I've had
there those who dislike me use we're
trying to link it with the latest
outrage this video that's come out that
some headline subscribers damning and
has filled very serious accusations
against me actually I think criminal
accusations of criminality and that I
was part
- violent criminal conspiracy conspiracy
or had knowledge of it that withheld it
from the authorities it's absolutely all
untrue I wish this video I actually
encourage everybody to watch it it's
kind of my washing paint dries 18
minutes so that was recorded on the 1st
of May
2019 May Day there were a series of
demonstrations throughout the day I had
been documenting it it was early in the
day that I have been punched in the
abdomen and sprayed with silly string
and so that happened all before this
video started there was a right-wing
demonstration where they were holding
flags of a bridge and after that was
over they were milling around the street
and walking around I was just following
them it was really uneventful it's
actually quite boring I was thinking I
was looking at my phone which you can
actually see in the video one to see how
the other journalists had covered the
protests from earlier in the day so does
anything else that I missed because it
was happening at different parts of the
city and I was trying to see if anybody
had caught video and me getting
assaulted so that's what I was looking
at and concentrated on I only heard
snips snippets of what these people are
talking about and none of it to me was
interesting it was like where are we
going to go is anybody else joining us
what's going on like so I didn't record
that it wasn't and I mind you I need to
point out I wasn't only photo journalist
I was there there are three other people
including a local left-wing journalist
by the way so none of us found I knew
this interesting there was at one point
where people have said some of the
headlines have been completely false
demonstrably false if you watch the
video it's saying that I lost while
people were planning a an attack I never
left in the video there's a one point
where I did give a faint smile I recall
them saying something about how they
were really outnumbered and I was just
at that time thinking about like this is
what you know they're always outnumbered
ten to one if they're lucky like this is
a futility of their demonstrations in
Portland and that was spun as me being
improving or supportive of whatever
happened next and I don't think it was
apparent to any of us there what was
going to happen next because even this
this video who was reported by an
undercover anti-fur activists someone
who had been undercover for two years
and this is like the climax of his work
right one it was selectively released in
that he doesn't show any any of what
happened actually up the ante for pub
that was hosting the anti-fog party
doesn't show any of that and that that
was where as I was seriously assaulted
there as well and so he loveed
accusations against me anonymously
it's an unverified well one is an
anonymous person so it's unverified
source and that it the fact is this he
was interviewed and it went on a on the
left wing blog and called the Portland
mercury which is also a paper and you
know it's like this whole like watching
myself being smeared in real time and
made until somebody or not has been
really fascinating kind of surreal it's
like seeing how it's a game of telephone
almost it's like this and all the
players are you know the the writers a
HuffPo box of ice and then all the
Twitter check marks people who kind of
parted the same left-wing Scorchers
partisan ideological right writers and
it's just like Oh some decide and he was
laughing when when he Andes laughing in
a damning video let's repeat on the
headlines and over and over over and it
just you know they really depend on
people not watching it what happened
next on in that video is well I went to
the bar and and actually in an interview
with this anti Anonymous interfere
activist he stopped recording at one
point not to call the police but to call
the people out the ante for party you
know so if this was if he was really
witnessing a violent criminal conspiracy
I wonder why
he didn't call police and this video
footage even at the very end of the
interview he said he didn't realize what
he had caught until much until some time
later before releasing it so it wasn't
apparent to him and he was right there
talking to the people and I was walking
around the area sometimes close mostly
far away as well as being concentrated
with things on my phone okay so just to
be clear what you're saying is at no
point did you feel that these people
were about to go and attack someone in a
bar I didn't have a full picture that
would have led me to that conclusion
correct
[Music]